what advice would you give me to make
sure that my relationship stays fresh
and new and spicy actually there's a
great study that when people their
sexual desire for the partner goes up Dr
T shered she's a neuroscientist author
one of the world's leading researchers
On Emotion decision making and how to
change our brains for the better this is
negatively affecting your life and you
don't know it we have a study where we
asked people what was your favorite part
on your vacation and we found the peak
of enjoyment was 43 hours into the
vacation and people used one word more
than any other word and it was the word
first the first view of the ocean the
first cocktail and then the joy goes
down and down and down why it's because
the input into your neurons is constant
and when things are not changing our
brain just stops responding and the
problem is that even if you're living
your absolute best life great
relationship a good job comfortable home
after a while those things don't bring
us the joy that they should cuz when
something is always in front of you you
stop attending to it that's true also
for the not so great thing around us
sexism racism cracks in our
relationships after a while we don't
notice them and if we don't notice them
we don't change them one reason why
happiness is low in midlife is because
things are a little bit more routine the
problem is we really don't like Risk
taking so how do we change that two main
things one is
quick one this is really really
fascinating to me on the back end of our
YouTube channel it says that
69.9% of you that watch this channel
frequently over the lifetime of this
channel haven't yet hit the Subscribe
button I just wanted to ask you a favor
it helps this channel so much if you
choose to just subscribe helps us scale
the guest helps us scale the production
and it makes the show bigger so if I
could ask you for one favor if you've
watched the show before and you've
enjoyed it and you like this episode
that you're currently watching could you
please hit the Subscribe button thank
you so much much and I will repay that
gesture by making sure that everything
we do here gets better and better and
better and better that is a promise I'm
willing to make you do we have a
[Music]
deal
tell welcome back thank you for having
me back to be here for those people that
aren't familiar with your career can you
give us a little bit of an overview of
your academic background but really I
guess the summary of the mission that
you're on and the work that you've done
what are you trying to understand what
is it that you're you're trying to do
with your professional life so in very
general terms I'm trying to understand
human behavior why do people do what
they do why do they feel the way that
they do um and I use a lot of different
methods to try to understand that so I
use Neuroscience method I really kind of
try to look inside people's brains also
I look at Behavior so I'm kind of
combining psychology brain science I
also combine economics to try to
understand motives to try to understand
needs um and hopefully use that not only
for us to understand human brains better
but also to make our life better perhaps
make better decisions for anyone that's
listening to this right now that is has
a vision of who they want to become and
it's different from who they currently
are in some way habits behaviors they
want to adopt is step one awareness is
that step one awareness of your own
cycles and thoughts and patterns one
thing you should concentrate on and be
aware of is what is already good about
yourself right so not only what do I
want to become which I'm not but what am
I which is great what already great
skills I have right personality traits I
have because those are things that you
can build on right and so look at it not
only in this kind of negative way but
look at it in a positive ways and so
once once you done that yes then we can
say okay this is my goal right and the
next thing is how do I go from where I
am to this goal and if you have a
specific plan and you you're not
necessarily going to follow that exact
plan right but if you have a plan and
you kind of really think through the
details what happens is that if you can
imagine that vividly that will then
create your belief that it's more likely
to happen right if we have a specific
plan concrete that makes us feel it's
more likely to happen and if we think
it's more likely to happen we're more
likely to follow through and then
there's a lot of little tricks of how to
get us to follow through uh one really
important one is looking at your
progress so say you want to go to the
gym
and at the first week you only go once a
week and then the next week you go twice
a week or maybe when you're go you go
the first time you go you're only
running on the treadmill for 10 minutes
right and then next time 20 minutes but
put down those numbers so you can
actually see them because when people
can actually see their progress that is
extremely motivating right you always
want to be a little bit above from where
you were so that's that's one thing
that's hugely important is there sort of
scientific research that supports this
idea that progress has a very sort of
motivational impact on people yes
absolutely there are great studies one
study that I'm thinking of um was where
people had to do a task which required
them to learn the rules and they would
get money um rewards for doing it well
and every so often they ask people how
are you feeling right now what they
found is yes when people got rewards
when they got money they were feeling
good but turns out that they felt the
best when they learned something new
right when they
progressed that's when they were really
feeling the best and there was there's
another study in which people could play
one of two games one game all the rules
were clear it was really easy for them
to do the best that they could do in
another game there was a bit of
uncertainty they had to learn it wasn't
clear right it was challenging to some
some respect and they could play those
two games and then every every few
minutes they said okay you could stay in
this game or you can move to the other
game what they found is people liked to
play the game where they had to learn
where there was uncertainty they did not
like to play the game where they always
did well where they not progressing
where there's nothing to learn so
progress is really something that we
strive for and when it happens that
really makes us feel better right it
makes us feel like we're moving forward
we don't like this St even if where you
are is great right really really great
after a while it's not enough right you
want to expand you want to progress
those subject matters appear in your new
book look again when you're talking
about the importance of variety in our
lives and it really shows up in all
aspects of Our Lives this need for
variety um which you're kind of talking
about there people want to try something
new they want to learn something new
they want to be stimulated in some way
it's very true in work you talk about
that a lot and as an employer it really
kind of hit me that one of the
most effective things I could do to keep
my team members motivated would probably
be to like change their jobs quite often
or at least add new elements to their
responsibilities quite often
yeah what the book is about is about
habituation and habituation is basically
the phenomena which governs basically
every part of our brain which is we
don't respond to things that don't
change when things are constant where
they're not changing our brain just
stops responding and once you do change
things around even a little bit then we
start responding
again and at work you know it's often
the case in in big companies for example
that that people will take employees and
will let them rotate through different
divisions once in a while right because
if you're staying at the same place
doing the same thing over and over and
over and over again you become
complacent to some extent right but once
you change you're now talking to maybe a
little different people maybe the
projects are a little bit
different then you start you start
encoding again it also enhances your
creativity the word habit uation is
quite a long word I'm sure most people
won't be familiar with the word probably
never heard it before I didn't hear
about habituation until I was doing a
lot of research ahead of my book and
came across a lot of your research but a
really interesting way to
illustrate what habit habituation is is
with images like this now tell me tell
me what's going on here we're going to
put this image on the screen and also
for those that of you that are listening
on audio there will be a link to this
image in the description of this episode
but but essentially when you look at
this image in the center of this image
for 30 seconds especially when you're
looking at it on a computer screen all
of the colors disappear if you stay
focused on that black dot in the middle
of this image for 30 seconds so this was
a discovery by um a Austrian physi
physician in 1804 what he discovered is
that if you look you have to not move
your eyes so fixate on the black cross
and don't move your eyes the colors
fade away they become gray and if you're
really good at this I've done this a few
times and I was I was able to do this
actually the gray goes away and the
whole thing just becomes
white why is that it's because the input
into your neurons if you're not moving
your eyes um is constant so the neurons
are just getting the same input so they
stop responding they're like well
there's nothing new here you know let's
save our resources for something else
that's going to come along so you stop
noticing the color all together and that
that is habituation now once you move
your
eyes color comes back right or if
anything moves in the background like
yeah well you do yeah yeah so then um if
you're moving your eyes then the input
into different norons change and then
you consciously perceive the colors
again and I think it's the same in our
life if everything is constant we don't
perceive the good and we don't perceive
the bad but if we move our eyes enough
you know
metaphorically then we'll start noticing
and feeling again do all animals do this
habituation thing yeah so it's something
really fundamental you see this in every
living creature um and I think to me
that's what's so interesting about this
right because something that seems to
affect every part of our life from our
relationships to our mental health to
our ability to innovate you can actually
track it down and you can see it's in
every living animal there's this
habituation the fact that neurons
respond less and less to things that
don't change right and that's true for
things just like sound if you hear the
same sound again and again and again and
again you're no longer conscious of it
you're no longer responding to it so
that's just perceptual habituation but
habituation is also true for the
fundamental things in our life that we
really care about and this is why people
can have really great things in their
life and I'm sure you do right maybe
like a great relationship a good job or
a comfortable home but what's
interesting is that after a while those
things don't bring us the Daily joy that
they should right because we kind of
habituate it to it sort of like what
what is thrilling on Monday becomes
boring on Friday and the interesting
thing is that's true also for the not so
great thing around us so there might be
bad things around us like uh sexism
racism cracks in our relationships or
inefficiencies at work but if they're
there all the time after a while we
don't notice them and if we don't notice
them we don't try to change them where
does this come from this this idea that
once we're exposed to something we kind
of phase out and can't see it
anymore it's because if something is in
front of us for a while and we're still
alive nothing bad happened right then
the brain doesn't really need to respond
to it anymore because the brain's trying
to conserve resources right right we
need the resources to be ready for the
new thing that is coming your way right
which can be threatening or it could
also be really great like you know food
or something that you should grab um and
that's that's basically why we stop
responding of course if someone
something is hurting you right you will
continue responding to that which is why
it's it's it's a little bit difficult to
habituate to pain that's one to pain
yeah yeah mhm what are some of your um
your favorite examples of everyday
habituation of everyday habituation yeah
like things that yeah yeah I told you
mine before we started recording which
was um if I go to the gym and then I
come home I can no longer smell myself
because you can I can smell myself for
maybe a couple of minutes when I'm
working out that I'm like getting hot
and sweaty but then once I'm around
myself for like 10 minutes I guess my
brain is just no longer sending the
signal from my armpits to my through my
nasal receptors to my brain yeah so
smell is is really a good one CU that
happens really really fast right so if
you put a perfume in yourself it really
smells strongly but then you put the
same perfume a day later you don't smell
it as much a week later you don't smell
it as much so those are really easy to
see around us but I think to me the more
interesting ones are habituating to
things that we um enjoy a lot and then
we enjoy less and less and less and
things things that are really bad but we
stop noticing so for example there's a
great study in which uh people were
asked to think about a song that they
like tell me a song that you like or
even an artist that you like oh gosh
there's one I'm listening to at the
moment house Gospel Choir angels
watching over me okay would you prefer
to hear that song from beginning to end
no interruptions or would you prefer to
hear it with
breaks with breaks yeah I don't want to
hear it with breaks okay you want to
hear it the full the full thing the full
thing right you think you would enjoy it
more correct yeah okay 99% of people say
exactly what you say right I'm going to
enjoy the song more if I just hear I
listen to it continuously with no breaks
but
counterintuitively when the study was
conducted it was shown that people
actually end up enjoying a song more if
there are Breaks by breaks you mean they
just put gaps in it gaps in it and in
fact what's more interesting is not only
did they put caps for different groups
of people they did different things
doing the gaps maybe there's quiet maybe
there's an annoying noise and it didn't
matter what they did in the gaps when
you had gaps in the song people enjoyed
it more which is really ctive right and
they were willing to pay twice as much
to hear that song in concert so why is
that so if you hear a song that you
really like it's really joyful but it
turns out that over the whatever two
minutes three minutes four minutes of
the song The Joy kind of goes down you
habituate a little bit right if you have
a break your the joy is quite and then
it starts going down there's a break and
so then you go back up right right and
so you habituate a little bit but then
you go back up so overall you're
enjoying the music more and they did the
same with massages so what do you prefer
a 1 hour massage or 20 minutes massage
break 20 minutes massage break 20
minutes massage break the 1 hour massage
why right again everyone says I prefer
the 1hour massage but again when they
did the study and they ask people how
much did you enjoy it the group who had
breaks ended up enjoying it more so what
you're saying is we need to put more
bloody adverts in this podcast it's
exactly what I this was exactly what I
was thinking people are loving the
adverts because you think you're you
know intellectually you think oh these
adwards are annoying but I think what's
happening and you know no one's actually
done this this exact experiment but they
should I think that in fact people may
enjoy your podcast more with the ads
even if you kind even if they go through
it like that it's a little Gap it is
possible and that was my fa exactly
comments now like we [__] don't want
anymore yeah and that's so interesting
and one of my favorite examples is
actually
vacation so holidays um so I did um I
was working on this project with a big
uh tourism company in the UK and they
wanted to know what makes people enjoy
holidays the most right when do they
enjoy the holiday the most and why so we
did surveys and we went on these resorts
to interview people and we found two
interesting things the first was that
the peak of enjoyment was 43 hours into
the
vacation and why is that well we think
the reason is that first you get to the
resort and then you have to unpack you
know all of that and then you start
really enjoying it and then the joy goes
down and down and down over time you're
still enjoying your holiday a lot but
the peak is within 43 hours and then the
related second uh bit of data that we
saw is that when we asked people what
was your favorite part of the vacation
people used one word more than any other
word and it was the word first so they
said the first view of the ocean the
first dip in the water first
cocktail right they enjoyed the second
time they went into the pool the third
time but they enjoyed the first the most
because firsts are kind of novel right
and then you habituate the second time
you enjoyed a little bit less than the
third time enjoy late you're still
enjoying it but not as much as the first
time so does that mean that for holidays
in I think you argue this point in the
book you do yeah about instead of doing
you know four week holidays it's much
better to do weekend breaks because if
it's 42 hours or so that's optimal
enjoyment right so you're trying to
think about how can I maximize my
enjoyment right and when it comes to
Vacation maybe one one good idea is
instead of going for a twoe vac during
the year maybe you know have a few long
weekends vacations now of course if
you're flying somewhere far then you
might not be able to do it it's a cost
and so on but you might consider instead
of going to the spway vacation for two
weeks maybe you want to go somewhere
closer to home but have more of them
because then you get more firsts you Al
also get more afterglows so that's when
you coming back from vacation and you're
still happy because you were just on
vacation and you're also getting more of
the anticipation of the vacation
interesting which is hugely beneficial
for your well-being the anticipation
part before um you're actually even
there at the resort or wherever you're
going I mean this begs the question
about the other thing we habituate to
which a lot of us don't want to admit
which is our partners and our sex lives
two things I've talked a lot on this
podcast about um as it relates to things
that we kind of get used to and then no
longer can get the same level of I don't
know pleasure happiness appreciation
gratitude from um does it apply to
relationships and sex yeah so I think it
does and I think the solution is very
similar breaks and I don't mean like a
relationship break right what I mean is
have you know an evening for yourself go
on a weekend perhaps on your own and
then when you come back everything kind
of respark is there any data to prove
this because it's a feeling something
that we all know intuitively like me and
my partner both know that when we're
spending time apart is good for our
relationship every relationship knows
that it's good for our sex life it's
good for our our appreciation of each
other but is there any data that
supports this yes and I I'll tell you
what the data is which is so obvious you
think is like why do people even do a
study about this but there's one study
and it simply shows that when people are
away from their partner their desire the
sexual desire for the partner goes up
what is it about our partner going away
that makes us want them more it's
related to habituation right but it's
also related to where your attention is
when something is always in front of you
you sort of stop attending to it because
it's always there and so your brain then
goes okay what else do I need to get
right but if they're not there then your
attention can go back to them and then
there is a more basic level of how
pleasure works there's this great quote
by The Economist Tyber kovski and he
says that pleasure results from
incomplete and intermittent satisfaction
of desires right incomplete yes so the
idea is that you always wanting a little
bit more okay right in mident meaning
there's breaks and then you always and
it's incomplete because you always want
a little bit more and I think that quote
is you can apply it to almost everything
right even to food there's another um
fun experiment where they have two
groups and one group was given mac and
cheese to eat which they really liked
every day for you know a few weeks and
of course they liked the mac and cheese
of the first day they liked it on the
second day but after a while they
couldn't you know they couldn't see mac
and cheese anymore they really did not
want mac and cheese um while the other
group got mac and cheese just once a
week and they enjoyed the mac and cheese
much more right and so it's true for
food it's true for music it's true for
our relationship
it's rof
fications what's that type what's that
restaurant where they the chef brings
you I don't know like 13 different
courses of food oh that's too much so
that's not good okay so here's here's
what I think about choices um you first
of all you don't want to give people no
choice at all right so if there's a
restaurant where you get no choice at
all I don't think that is overall a good
idea I mean what you could do for
example if you want if you want to have
a restaurant where there's an OP
that the chef decides still make it a
choice right so you can have on the menu
Chef's Choice but I'm still you know
sitting there and deciding okay the chef
is going to choose for me but that's
still my choice why does that matter
because um it is well known that first
having a choice is really important for
people's sense of control and for for
their enjoyment and once they choose
something they like it better than if
someone else choose for them they really
you know one thing that we really don't
like humans really don't like and
actually other animals as well is having
no agency having no choice that causes
anxiety so we do want to make sure that
people have a choice at the same time
you don't want to have too many options
because that can be overwhelming right
there's the um famous experiment where
people are given an option to choose
between 60 different jams and some
people people are so overwhelmed they
just leave the store empty-handed so you
don't want to go to right too much
choice that could be just overwhelming
because there's you know for like too
much cognitive resources right anything
that that we do that
requires an amount of cognitive resource
that is above some kind of threshold can
feel
aversive right so having a choice where
you have to choose too many things
that's not good on the other hand not
being able to choose
anything that's not good either so you
want to be somewhere in in the middle
going back to this this subject matter
of relationships what advice would you
give me based on everything you know
about habituation to make sure that my
relationship stays spicy and uh we go
the long term what things can I you know
what do I need to be aware of what what
things can I do okay so just thinking
about like habituation related things I
would say two main things one is
meaning having some distance once in a
while right okay and the second is doing
new things together okay right because
if you're always doing the same thing
over and over and over which couples
sometimes do they're like a few things
that they like to do right because it's
hard because each person has their own
preferences of what they like and then
you find an overlap and that overlap is
not necessarily huge so then you just
you know do the same thing over and over
over so I think as a couple it is good
to explore and I just don't necessarily
mean like sexually but just everything
like what type of movies you're going to
watch and you know what type of
activities and that can also expand your
experiences I think together right on
the point of sex though I do think sex
can get boring if you don't constantly
try new things it's just it's if you
plan to be with someone for 50 years
finding new things to try is
work to be honest and I guess life is
work so it's work worth doing you know
I'm almost almost I know almost five
years into my relationship with a little
bit of a gap in between and it's a
conversation we've had a lot which is
how do we keep things fresh and new and
interesting and spicy because like any
couple or like any people you fall into
as you say like Comfort habits we go to
this restaurant because we know it and
they know us you know you go to this
place because you know the place and you
that's your favorite restaurant there or
whatever you watch this this thing on TV
you follow this okay this cycle of
Monday to Monday to Sunday Monday we do
this then Saturday and Sunday we do this
you know and it can be it can the
monotony can seem to take a joy out of
life right yes and I think you want a
little bit of balance so some of this
kind of routine and things you're
familiar with there's something nice
about that as well right so it's not I'm
not saying every weekend do something
completely new right but just so you
have your kind of routine and then you
know you insert some novel activities or
something something new so it's it's
kind of a b a balance between exploring
new things but also exploiting the
things that you enjoy do you think
there's a because I was thinking about
it as you were speaking about men and
women if there's a difference in their
ability to habituate and in my
experience maybe that's just because
I've always been the man in the
situation um I'm less likely to seek
spontaneity
I think in terms of like coming up with
new ideas for places us to go my
girlfriend she's so like let's go to
this flower thing let's go to this then
let's go to this player let's go over
here she's very explorative so I was
just wondering if there was a variance
you'd ever seen in any research about a
man's ability to habituate versus a
woman's no I haven't so I don't
necessarily think there is and I don't
necessarily think that it is a case that
men are more explor explorative or more
um in but and this is not Based on data
this is just my observation I often hear
that people say I like to explore but my
partner yeah likes to do the same or I
like to just do the same all the time
but my partner likes to explore I hear
this again and again it's true in my own
relationship my my co-author Cass
Einstein who wrote the book with me um
he also says exactly the same right so
for him he likes to exploit and his wife
likes to explore for me it's like I like
to explore my husband likes to exploit
and I hear this again and again and that
makes me think that it is not a
coincidence um that is perhaps the case
that people who like to explore end up
with people who like to exploit because
to do the best that we can in life we
need to do both so maybe it is you know
this balance interesting to individuals
because if you're left on your own and
just exploring all the
time you might not get to the optimal
balance in life mhm if you're exploiting
all the time then you're unlikely to
find these new things right that will
actually be great for you you will learn
gain you pleasure and so on so um it may
not be a coincidence and I think in in a
lot of these traits almost every
psychological traits that you can think
of they are individual differences you
can go all the way from one extreme to
The Other Extreme right if we're talking
about optimism all the way to pessimism
exploration all the way to exploitation
right and everything in the and Norm
it's kind of a bell curve of sorts um
and I think it's not a coincidence right
because if you think about a society a
group a team working together you do
need these variations for people to push
each other in different directions such
that as a team we get to the best that
we can we can get we talked about
learning a little bit earlier on and
about the importance of of change and
Novelty I'm someone that's just Fallen
back into the habit of reading books
again and writing about them and it's
brought a huge amount of lost joy to my
life and I and I had almost lost sight
of it through becoming so busy in my
professional life I'd lost the um Joy of
learning new things and because I do
this podcast as well and it seems to I
learn so much from speaking to the
people I speak to but just recently
getting back into reading books again
has brought this new sort of excitement
to my life and your book is is provides
a lot of evidence as to why that might
be yeah I think it is it is a case that
probably you know know in recent years
people are reading less right um and we
kind of forget the joy of reading
whether it is fiction or
non-fiction I think the difference
between reading a book than watching a
video is when you read a book there's an
extra mental activity that you're doing
which is you're imagining you're
visualizing right it's also in your own
pace so you read something and maybe
that elicit triggers some kind of
Association in your mind right so you
might like stop for a little bit and
then continue so there's so much more
going on and I think because of that
when you read a book you can relate that
more to yourself and to your own life
right versus I mean watching I mean
films like that that's great as well but
that that is a difference right it's
more about you and your inner
experiences and memories coming more
alive and then it also ties to what you
already know the midlife crisis is this
a real thing yeah absolutely it is well
known that stress is the peaks in your
midlife and happiness um goes down in
your midlife suicide for example Peaks
especially for male um in midlife
definitely like something that we should
think of and notice um and we don't
really know for sure why it happens but
one thing that happens in midlife is
that you have a lot of
coming your way um so we're talking
about 40s and 50s so you have you might
need you have little kids that you need
to take care of maybe you have elderly
parents that you're worried about uh
professional life has a lot of stressors
in midlife so that's really a time where
we see the midlife crisis but one thing
that we think is that perhaps this is
also a time that you're not progressing
as much right so kind of in your 20s and
so on you learn a lot lot you gain
skills you get to perhaps a good
position and then it's sort of
plateauing right for a lot of people it
can kind of plateau in midlife perhaps
they have a good job right but they're
kind of stuck they're not really moving
as much they're not learning as much
less variety right things are a little
bit more routine and that could be one
reason why happiness is relatively low
in midlife
it's also hard to see like what is next
sometimes right while you're climbing up
it's you're kind of well this is my goal
but once you get there it's a little bit
disappointing to some extent even if
you've done really well right because as
we talked before one thing that is
really important for our happiness is
kind of us believing that we have
something to gain something to go
forward to now why does then happiness
go back up after midlife right so we
don't know but here is one speculation
that at at a certain point in time uh
maybe you're
retiring then actually Life Changes
again right in an odd way there can
actually be more variety and in change
in learning you need to learn how to
live life again with this new context of
not going to work every day and you know
and you might make decisions all sorts
of decisions of what to do with your
time which will require you to learn
again when you get s say 40 40 50 years
old
you're probably in a relationship which
you've been in for a while there's not
that there's not that Pursuit your job
your career your profession your
identity your geography your house
friendship circles are probably all well
established at that point and your
hypothesis is that the lack of forward
motion and the abundance of routine
means that you lose something in life
yeah so things are less new right it's
kind of same same same imagine the best
day of your life you wake up in the
morning and you eat like the best
breakfast that you can think of right
choose and then you you interact with
the people that you love the most and
you go do the best activity like what
you want and you see your favorite movie
so the whole day is your favorite
favorite favorite favorite things really
great and then you wake up the same the
next day and you do the same and then
you wake up the next day and you do the
same right week in a few weeks in the
best day of your life just doesn't
elicit as much joy right and also
there's nothing to learn anymore so even
if you're living your absolute best life
if it is the same again and again and
again and again it will eventually be a
little bit even depressing I would say
so that's by definition not our best
life right so so then it is what is our
best life so I think when people think
think about what my best life is what
they're thinking about is oh I want that
great house right I want that great
partner I want money or you know and
then you can get all of these things but
if they remain constant that's just not
going to be your best life and you can
engineer this I mean even if it's like
midlife and everything is set and you're
in one house and so on for example you
can go take a course learn something new
right a new field that is not your own
you can
a new sport right there's things that
you could do go visit places that you
haven't been try to um make connections
with people that are a bit different
from your regular crowd that you're
interacting with it's a little bit hard
to do because it's going to require
effort the easiest thing to do is just
continue same same same same same we
assume that happiness will be derived
from us
um I almost don't know how to say this
like from us being on autopilot like if
we do what societ said you work a job
you get a partner you create a house we
assume that will lead to happiness but
what you're saying is the research shows
that we actually need to keep almost
dismantling or disrupting our own
experience to to find happiness or to be
happy I guess we can't find happiness we
be happy Yeah there did a whole bunch of
surveys to figure out what are the
factors that are most associated with
people's happiness and the number one
was meaning right people who could say I
have meaning in my life that was number
one number two was control people who
felt they have control over their life
um and I don't remember what number
income was but it wasn't especially high
oh I think social so social connections
was really high as well right so a lot
of these things were these psychological
things not necessarily material things
that really induced uh people's
happiness and satisfaction from their
life somewhat linked to that studies
show that after getting married people
report to being happier on average yet
about 2 years after their honeymoon
period happiness levels tend to be the
same as their pre-marriage levels yeah
so this is a well-known What's called
the hedonic treadmill oh yeah so the
hedonic treadmill means that we sort of
have a baseline level of Happiness which
is determined a lot is genetic it might
be determined by early childhood
experiences and we can move from that
Baseline we can go up if something good
happens maybe you have a good
relationship marriage uh you get a
promotion it can go down if something
bad happens even
bereavement but it turns out that in
most cases you climb back to your
Baseline level of Happiness so these
things they can go up and they come down
and then you kind of adapt right um and
at you end up trying you know and this
goes back to this idea that we're trying
to get all these things we think of once
I get this promotion and then I'll be
really happy and then you get the
promotion and it's great but then after
a while you just go back to your
Baseline now on on one hand this
actually is not a bad thing because
imagine you get your first entry level
job and people are really happy with
their first entry level job great but
imagine I just continue being really
happy with my first entry level job
right I won't be motivated to move
forward right so this is why habituation
is there because it's moving us forward
as an individual and and as a society on
the other hand it also reduces our joy
um and it also sometimes causes us not
to see some of the bad things around us
because we habituate to that as well
another reason why habituation is
important is for your mental health
right and that's kind of related to what
we just talked about where bad things
happen and slowly slowly slowly we adapt
and we go back to Baseline we are able
to recover right it's kind of our super
super power our immense ability to just
bounce back for most individuals and
what's interesting is that you actually
see that people with depression they
habituate much
slower so there is a great study that
was conducted in the University of
Florida by Professor Aaron heler where
he had students um who just got exam
results and he asked them how they were
feeling and then he asked them how they
were feeling after every 45 minutes for
the whole day and what he found is when
people got bad results they were feeling
bad right they're not happy and that's
true for people who never had depression
episodes in their life and people who
were experiencing depression or had
depression before so everyone was
feeling bad at the beginning those
people who did not have any history of
depression they slowly slowly slowly
started feeling better from this bad
grade those with depression also started
feeling better but much slower right so
in other words depression is related to
slower habituation slower recovery from
negative events in your life and one
reason we think this is is because
depression is related to going over
these bad events in your mind again and
again not letting go right you're kind
of like chewing over them again and
again and again and that is something
that is preventing you from recovering
and bouncing back from these um aversive
events
if um habituation
is causes us
to lose the joy of our current situation
then how come as you say in Chapter 2
the chapter about variety you say that
up to 40% of employees resign within the
first six months of their new job you'd
think their new job would bring them Joy
because it was different but up to 40%
of employees resign within the first 6
months so new things can bring us joy
because they're different however at the
same time and this kind of goes back to
the vacation example that I gave you
which was people are not the happiest
when they just get to the resort it
takes them time right it takes them 43
hours to get to the peak Joy why because
they still need the time to adapt right
they need to unpack they need to get
used to this new routine same thing with
a new job for example so on one hand
getting a new job you're going to learn
things and that's great and eventually
it will get you Joy but when you f when
you're there for the first day or the
first few days there's a lot of getting
used to things around you right you need
to like figure who's who right who's on
top who's in the bottom like where is a
cafeteria what am I going to eat there's
so many different things that you need
to figure out it can be stressful it can
be
overwhelming and you often want to just
like run back to your old life run back
to your new job and do a U-turn and the
problem is that often people don't
predict this
they can't see ahead right they think
it's like well I'm unhappy with my new
job on my first day or my second day or
even the first week that means that this
is not a good job for me you know
perhaps it's not a good job for you or
perhaps you just need to allow it some
time to adapt so you know my
recommendation is whatever it is that
you're trying that's new it can also be
something like a new relationship right
give it some time because you're going
to have to get used to the things that
are also not great you will also get
things you get used to things are great
but you have to get used to those things
that are not great and then after a
while you won't see them anymore right
so not going to affect you as much so
give it time now if you gave it time and
still you're unhappy sure yeah make a
change there's a clear message in here
for managers employees CEOs Founders
about how to keep their team motivated
and engaged and the message that I'm
hearing is the importance in creating
Variety in their work because I always
think in businesses I'm involved and if
someone's doing the same thing for like
12 months we're going to have a have to
have a conversation within the next 3
months because they will typically come
to me and say like something's not
something's not right and it's typically
that people need a bit of variety in
their work I guess because that gives it
a little kick of meaning again you know
I I think I've always hypothesized that
people need like five things to really
like their jobs number one is a sense of
Forward Motion towards a a goal so
that's progress I guess feeling like
you're going make making Forward Motion
number two challenge they need to be
like sufficiently challenged not too
challenged because then there's lots of
issues under challenged lots of issues
lose motivation like in game psychology
number three is control and autonomy so
feeling like you've got control over
your life your work number four is
meaning in the work you're doing
subjective meaning Jack's reason for
doing this podcast will be entirely
different from someone else in the team
for example and then the last one is
working in like a supportive group of
people there's a lot of studies about
this that you want a situation where
you're learning something because if
you're learning nothing people are not
engaged right but if it's like so
difficult that you can't learn right
people aren't happy as well so you have
to be like in this the spot in the
middle right that's a sweet spot and
again it's different for everyone right
where it's not too easy but it's not too
difficult so you have something to learn
but you're still progressing and that's
very important there's a great study
showing that if you put people in a room
and there's absolutely nothing for them
do except to shock themselves they will
shock themselves like little shock I
don't mean you know um this this paper
was actually in science a few years ago
so meaning that boredom can be so
aversive to people they would actually
prefer physical pain than to just not do
anything at all so that's on the one
hand and then of course on the other
hand is when you're sitting in in a you
know in a class or you're listening to a
lecture and you have no idea what's it's
too much right because you have gotten
there maybe you'll take the steps
eventually you'll get there but but you
know you started off by saying for
employees you need to kind of change
right give them different projects and
so on and what's interesting not only
will they enjoy it more they're more
likely to get to Creative Solutions
start with the fact that what what has
been found is that people who habituate
slower are more creative um so there's
different ways to measure how fast you
habituate what they did in this study is
that they had a sound the same sound
again and again and again and they
measured K conductance which shows um so
it is how aroused you are when you're
aroused you sweat more okay and that is
measured by the skin conductance right
and so when there's like a sound there's
a response so if a sound is the same
sound again and again and again most
people habituate there's no longer
response you know long skin conductance
but for some people they continue
responding right because they're not
habituating and what was found is those
those people who continue responding
those were the people who already showed
creativity in their life they had a
patent under their name they had an
exhibition in an art gallery they had a
book that they wrote they had um got
prizes for Innovative work and the
question is why is that and I think the
reason is that because of habituation we
filter a lot of information right and
you know it makes sense information is
not important but if don't habituate
you're going to have a lot of bits of
information in your mind simmering
objects sounds bits and pieces of
knowledge that are not important on
their own but they're just going to stay
in your mind they're going to simmer and
once in a while they will create
something new and that's where
Innovation comes in and really if you
think about the most Creative Solutions
that people come up with it's usually
they take something from one field
something really boring un important
mundane and that bit of mundane piece of
information then solves a problem in
this other completely different field
and or there's like this part of
knowledge here that is boring and this
other part of knowledge in this other
field that also seems very mundane but
you put them together and suddenly you
create something that is really really
interesting uh and creative right I mean
often you see for example people taking
what they know from bi
ology which you know on its own doesn't
seem so important but then they take
that and they use it to solve a problem
in a different field technology for
example right that is like the most
Creative Solutions so how do we
facilitate that how do we facilitate
dishabituation in order to enhance
creativity and the answer is change
changing your environment and it could
be simple things there studies showing
that if you just just change your
environment let's say you're working in
the office for a few hours and you go
work for in a coffee shop for a few
hours right that change can actually
also enhance creativity um you're
sitting and working and then you're
going out and walking or going out for a
run um studies show for the first six
minutes you're going to be more creative
and also vice versa so if you were out
walking out running and then you come
back and you sit in your office for the
next six minutes you're going to be more
creative now six minutes may sound like
that's not a lot of time but sometimes
it's just enough for you to get the aha
moment I can remember those instances
where I came up with an idea that would
then change my course of research for a
long time those ideas that were really
important so if I think about these
examples like one example was I was in
the office trying to solve this problem
and I couldn't find a solution so I
decided to go to the gym and then so I
walked to the gym and then before while
I was walking while I was getting to the
gym that's when you know the solution
came about and I remember like calling
my student and like sharing that and
that would then change years of what we
we were going to do right so just all I
did was changed my physical activity
change just my physical surrounding and
that's exactly what these studies show
um or another example was again I was in
my office and I took a break and I was
reading the New York Times science
section so not hugely different but
still different right and then I read
something about monkeys and I do humans
and that again that was ooh that an idea
came about by taking a break and doing
something that was a little bit
different and I think every single
example of this it's always like that
it's never me trying to think of
something new me trying to find a
solution it's always doing something
else which then something unusual not
something that I do like 90% of the time
in a day and that during those times is
when these kind of new ideas came about
you know the brain generally having
spent so much time studying it what are
the the fundamental surprises you've
come to learn about humans that you
think most people just don't understand
or agree with like the things that we
don't want to believe about ourselves
that are unfortunately
true things that are unfortunately true
I see this I read this throughout your
work things where you go humans wouldn't
say they like that if you asked them but
clearly they are because of the research
right yeah I mean it is true that we're
not conscious of most of these kind of
systematic mistakes that we make and the
biases that we have for example I mean
maybe our belief system is a great
example of why we believe what we
believe I think that if you'd ask people
why do you believe a certain thing they
would probably give you some kind of
rational explanation right I believe
this thing because you know here's all
the evidence and so forth but in fact
most of the times the reason we believe
something is that we were brought up in
an environment where that belief was a
popular one or people around us Believe
it or we've heard it again and again you
know one interesting thing is this is a
huge effect where people are are not
aware of it as long as you hear
something um repeatedly even twice the
likelihood that you believe it goes way
up versus something that you hear once
it's called the illus truth effect you
just there's so many studies showing
this you let people you you tell people
something twice they don't remember that
they've heard it twice and they're going
to believe it way more than something
that they just heard once um the reason
for this is that the brain process
information that it's heard before less
right okay so let's say I tell you that
um a shrimp's heart is in its head right
so when you hear that that sounds really
surprising and your brain takes a lot of
resources to process this you might
think about the last time I ate a shrimp
um right or just imagine the shrimp's
heart is in his head but the second time
I'm going to tell you this a shrimp's
heart is in his head your brain's not
going to process this at much right in
the third time it's not going to process
it at all now when your brain takes less
effort in processing things that causes
um a signal of
familiarity and as a result we're more
likely to believe something when
something requires less effort and less
energy to process
we believe it
more so anything that you hear again and
again and again as you hear it more and
more and more it takes less energy to
process and if it takes less energy to
process our brain then concludes that is
is likely true and for good reason
because most of the time when you hear
something again and again again most of
the time it's true so if you heard
something from you know your aunt and
then you heard it from your friend and
then you heard it from your doctor why
do all the people tell you all these
things because on average it's true but
sometimes it's not going to going to be
true right it's going to be false
beliefs right and even even things like
it takes you less energy to process a
large font 14 font bold it takes us less
energy to process it versus like small
font yeah we see that across the board
in all of our marketing companies is
that if we just make the font a little
bit bigger we get more clicks so it a
tiny bit click yeah not only are people
more attentive they're going to believe
it more so there's studies showing that
you show people two sentences um one is
in big fonts Boldt one is in small and
you ask them you know How likely is this
to be true How likely is that to be true
those sentences that are in big bald
fonts people are more likely to believe
they're true because the brain requires
less energy to process it which then
makes us conclude that it's likely to be
true and it's true for like for example
if you do it with like red color right
anything that makes it easier for for us
to process if we hear things more
clearly we're more likely to believe
that's true than if you put a little bit
of noise um people are less likely to
believe things are true anytime that
it's hard for us to process so what that
means is if you want people to um if you
want to help them believe what you're
saying right take on your
recommendations you want to make it
easier for them to process it so you
could do that visually big fonts red so
on but the other things you can do is
you can relate it to things that they
already believe in what we call priors
right so if I I want to convince you of
something it might be a good idea for me
to think about what are you what do you
already believe right and then try to
tie that to what you already believe
because that will require less
processing or I could tell you something
twice a free times now of course this
does it's not like I'm going to tell you
something really really crazy right the
Earth is flat three times and you're
going to believe me right but I'm
talking about these things where like it
could be true right and so I tell you
that a few times and then eventually you
you more likely to believe it and you
don't know it's because you've heard it
a few times so if I
said salad and sugar are good for
you versus just sugar is good for you
maybe more people are more likely to
believe the first sentence because I've
included a statement that you know from
prior knowledge is true which is cabbage
is good that that is a great example
that is a great example okay because our
brain goes yeah salad is good for you
and then you know by the time we get to
Sugar We're like okay that could be true
and also it makes you be more believable
and just to say you need a little bit of
sugar sugar is not only bad yeah right
little bit so you talked little about
DEH habituating Our
Lives why why and where do we need to
DEH habituate Our Lives what where do we
need to change things and introduce
novelty I'm almost wanting to come away
with a little bit of a little bit of a
checklist for my own life here I feel
like I'm I understand the part in
relationships which is take breaks from
my partner try new things with them you
said as well so go to new restaurants go
to new places do new things on the
weekend in work um
quit my job I guess that's what you're
saying no absolutely not no do not quit
your job you know change role add
responsibilities yeah but you could it
could even be something as I mean you
don't have to completely change what
you're doing but you could at the same
time try something new and in fact you
know from from you know I'm sure you do
that because you have different things
that you're doing right and so that
means you have Variety in your day
because you do your podcast but then you
also your companies and your companies
are different right so this is a good
example but not everyone has that right
A lot of people just have the one job
but if you can take on you know learn
something new right induce variety into
your day in that way that is great that
will cause you to start being on kind of
a learning mode right I take also from
that that as an employer it's really
important that we have all of our team
members on a personal development plan
which means making sure that they've got
intellectual Forward Motion in their
lives they're always learning something
new they're always striving for
something new and that every team member
in like my company should have something
they're currently learning about outside
of their core responsibilities right so
sometimes it's it would look like
they're going sideways yeah right so
sometimes it doesn't look like the the
path is like just progressing forward
but sometimes perhaps the plan is to go
a little bit sideways which sideways
which means like it's not the obvious
thing yeah that they're going to learn
right for their role see something not
going to become a better editor or
producer or whatever he's going to learn
music almost anything different that you
learn is probably going to feedb yeah
right yeah I guess it's it comes right
down to even the route you cycle on the
way to work in the morning or small
things right small decisions you make
hotels you stay out the airline you
choose to use is is there any other ways
that you've DEH habituated in your life
Having learned about this yes but I I
want to just say something about you
said use different aines and so on so on
one hand yes but on the other hand if
something is not super enjoyable but you
still have to do it so for example maybe
flying maybe travel like when you're
traveling for business it can be painful
right so in those cases in fact you want
to do the same thing again and again why
because you habituate to the negative
you see so if you think about things
that you don't like to do um you may
actually want to do it in the same way
over and over okay right because I mean
unless you think like you get on a plane
and you're super enjoying but like you
know for me I just like want it to be
over with right so it's easier actually
to use the same airline to do the same
thing so in some parts of your of life
actually you want to choose to do the
same thing and in fact in some parts of
life you want to um do these things that
you don't enjoy in one chunk you know
how we talked about the good things you
chop up MH the bad things you want to
swallow a whole so if you think about
things that you don't like to do but you
really need to do like I don't know I
need to grade papers I need to do house
household chores when you ask people
like would you rather do this thing that
you need to do but you don't like would
you just get it over with um in one go
or do you want breaks and between for a
breather people like breaks for a
breather right um if it is like I don't
know washing the floor or whatever they
is doing their taxes they want the braks
but in fact they suffer less if they
just get it over with because then they
habituate to the
negative yeah right yeah makes sense so
for the positive you want variety and so
on and but the things that you're not
going to learn a lot from you just need
to get them over and done with just get
them over and done with and even do it
exactly the same way that you've over
always done it is social media going
going to make me vicariously habituate
i. through looking at other people's
lives and the experiences they're having
it's moving my bar up like my my own
perception of expectations in my life up
in an unpleasant way so that when I go
to that same place that Jenny went to on
Instagram it's less enjoyable for me
because I've already kind of experienced
it through the lens of Jenny's Instagram
stories right so this has a lot to do
with what do you what do we expect from
life and how do those expectations
impact us MH
um so I think obviously social media is
causing us to have unrealistic
expectations we always I don't know for
most of us we feel kind of disappointed
with ourselves we go online is because
of course a lot of people go online and
the post the good things right oh I'm on
vacation I got this award and then you
go online and you're like oh all the
people all this good things are
happening constantly and so you feel
disappointed about your own life you
have unrealistic
expectations um and it it shifts what we
call adaptation level so basically we
adapt to um our daily life and then
things that are better than our daily
life we feel good and things are worse
we feel worse but sometimes our
adaptation level can shift not based on
our
reality but what we expect maybe will
happen and also what we see other people
are doing so let's talk about expecting
what will happen so it's there's a study
showing that when prisoners are about to
be
released they are still in prison but in
their mind they're already like thinking
about the release which is great and so
now their expectations are kind of
higher and that makes them feel worse
right so they're actually very close to
release but in fact they're feeling
really bad
because their their daily life is much
worse from what they expect their daily
life to be that's kind of like social
media isn't it you're sat in your house
looking out at people partying in some
hot Sunny Country having the time of
their lives you feel like you're in
prison your expectations are being
raised because you're watching them have
the time of their lives so suddenly your
house feels like you know a prison yeah
so your expectations can be based on
what you just expect for yourself and
also what other people are doing now I'm
not saying that um
high expectations are bad right because
there's two things happening at the same
time one thing is when um the outcomes
so this is related to dopamine neurons
so basically dopamine neurons in your
brain are firing all the time right and
then when outcomes are better than
expected they fire even more burst more
right so you expect to get this amount
of salary you get a higher salary
dopamine goes up you expect the steak to
take tastes quite good it tastes even
better they fire more and when things
are worse than expected they start um
quieting down right so they're quieting
down when things are worse than expected
and that is highly correlated with your
mood when there's big burst of dopamine
you feel good when the dopamine is quiet
you're feeling bad but that quiet is
important because that quiet says things
are not as good as I expected them to be
and it signals to your brain I need to
learn something I need to change this
right there's two things you can change
you can change your expectations you can
lower them or you can change the reality
right and so this negative mood that is
associated with outcomes not being um as
good as you expected them can actually
lead to progress so it's a bit of a
delicate kind of balance right and so
often I mean there's this really
counterintuitive finding which is when
people people don't have certain things
in their life for example in countries
where the Health Care system is quite
bad the Health Care System doesn't
affect people's daily happiness as much
as in countries where the Health Care
system is good so when the healthcare
system is good you expect it to be good
so then any variation can impact your
your kind of satisfaction but if you're
living in a country we like well I know
the healthcare system is bad I'm it's
not going to even affect how I'm feeling
right you have no expectation and you're
kind of that's not going to impact your
happiness how much do you really know
about your health for me that answer was
simple the answer was very little until
whoop came along as you guys know they
sponsored this podcast but even before
then whoop was integral for me to know
what's going on inside my body most of
my friends my family and my team now use
whoop but I still have a few friends
that are on the fence about getting on
board and what I hear from some of those
friends is that they're a little bit
worried about what they might see in the
data and they might feel uncomfortable
about knowing what's going on inside
their body if I have learned anything it
is that knowledge is power and once I
finally started to look at the data and
understand how getting less sleep was
affecting my body and how my old
lifestyle was actually hurting my
long-term Health everything changed for
the better so if this is something that
you'd like to try out head over to join.
whoop.com
CEO and you'll get to try whoop for 30
days risk-free with zero commitment try
it and let me know how you get on let's
talk about Zoe who you may know because
they're a sponsor of this podcast and
I'm an investor in the company you guys
know health is my number one priority
Zoe's growth story has been absolutely
incredible so far they're doing science
at a scale that I've never seen before
because of their members and recent
breakthroughs in research they can now
continue to offer the most
scientifically Advanced gut health test
on the market previously the test
allowed them to analyze 30 bacteria
types in in your gut but now thanks to
new science they've identified a 100
bacteria types this is a huge step
forward and there's nothing else that's
available even close to it on the market
at all so to find out more and to get
started on your Zoe Journey visit
zoe.com
stepen you can use my exclusive code
ce10 for 10% off don't tell anybody
about that okay just for you guys I
remember you had a TED Talk didn't you
which did uh 15 million views on how to
motivate yourself to change your
Behavior okay yeah what can I take from
that Ted talk to achieve my new year new
me
goals okay so um I talk about a few
principles there and one
is a lot of time our goals are in the
future so I want to go to the gym
because eventually I want to lose weight
I'm not going to lose weight that very
second right I'm not going to like get
into my jeans that very day eventually I
know that if I go to the gym I will
become healthier right so it's all a lot
of times about the future or you say I
want to get a promotion so I'm going to
work really hard today so I can get
promotion in the
future the problem is that it's really
hard to motivate yourself to do
something
immediate for a reward that's going to
come a long time from now so what you
need to do is you need to figure out
what can I get now I'm going to the gym
because I want to be healthier and you
know thinner or whatever in the future
but is there anything that I can get at
the very moment um I've heard people
tell me that the way that they motivate
themselves to get the gym is they say
when I get to the gym and I get on the
treadmill I'm going to allow myself to
watch some trash TV or uh read like you
know a magazine that I don't always
allow myself to read so that's one thing
right think about what the immediate
rewards that you can give yourself or
someone else maybe you're helping
someone else to to achieve their goals
what can we get immediately not only in
the future for for example another
person told me that their husband um
they really wanted their husband to go
to the gym and so the husband went to
the gym and they got back and the wife
um said to the husband oo I can feel
your like I can see your muscles right
so it was immediate right they gave him
like immediate rewards so try to think
about I call it like um Bridge the
temporal Gap because there's an action
happening today and there's this like
goal in the future but you have to
bridge the temporal Gap to try to think
about okay what can I also get now it
could be an emotional response right I
mean a lot of times when we do something
like we work hard we solve a problem we
go to the gym we feel good it could be
the emotional response so maybe one way
you can do is make that Salient right
maybe like track your your emotions
track your mood and you can say okay
this is what I did today right I went to
the gym today this is how I was feeling
right and so that's also an immediate
reward I was thinking about this idea of
discipline and what creates discipline
and I was hypothesizing ing if there
were to be a discipline equation what it
might look like and I kind of concluded
that there's three parts to the things
and areas in my life where I've been
able to maintain discipline and the
equation looks something like this the
start of the equation would be the why
like however much I valued that goal so
it could be going to the gym or
whatever Plus the reward that I got from
the pursuit of the goal so the perceived
reward I got from the pursuit of the
goal so that's actually like going to
the gym doing the exercise being on the
treadmill the feeling after walking home
like the you know and then minus the
cost of the pursuit of the goal so
that's like having to like leave the
house get in the Uber put my shoes on
travel for 45 minutes was you know use
lose two hours and if you want to be
disciplined in any are of your life you
need to therefore increase the why in
whatever way you can get really really
clear on why that matters and in your
case create those packs like a social
pack to financial pack whatever to make
it really important to you do whatever
you can to make the reward of the
pursuit of the goal more enjoyable might
be going with a friend or something
going to a gym that's closer I don't
know and then do everything you can to
reduce the cost of the pursuit of the
goal so right and the problem is that
the costs are often immediate yeah right
and then we we fall into What's called
the present bias or sometimes it's
called temporal discounting which is
that often we value what's happening in
the moment more than the same thing if
it was to happen in the future right um
and that's true for both like bad things
and good things things that are just
happening now our brain is like oh I'm
going to decide what to do based on this
immediate thing and the problem is that
the costs are often immediate right to
go 100% go to the gym yeah they come
first right so you have to overcome
those costs and I think one and as
you're saying one thing you could do is
to try to get those rewards closer in
time right so if I go to to the gym I
have to like walk to the gym I might
tell myself okay I can listen to podcast
while I'm walking so that's enjoyable
exactly exactly while I'm running yeah
Simon siic threw a really when I was at
his house talking to him about this he
threw an objection at me he was like
yeah but this morning in La I got out of
bed and went and emptied the bins at 7
a.m. because I knew if I didn't then
there' be repercussions so I ran that
through this framework and I was like
well your y was strong because the
repercussions of you not getting out of
bed are the B overflows you probably get
fined by the local Council the reward of
the pursuit of the goal really was
wasn't there and the cost fortunately
was lower than the Y so discipline
occurred right and and that's because
we're a sophisticated creatures right
we're not only driven I mean those
things immediately are are strong but
we're not only driven by them we have
these frontales right we're
sophisticated creature we can value
things that are in the future so when
I'm saying and I say you know immediate
is important I'm not saying future isn't
important for us and we don't use that
we do right and we're able to do that um
another thing that people do is they
actually put in artificial costs for not
doing the right thing interesting like a
social practice one where I've announced
it to the world world on my Instagram
that I'm going to do it then there's a
reputational cost if I don't right right
and uh for example you know there's
those silly things where people say I've
heard this when uh for writers and they
tell I tell the friends you know I'm
going to send you my chapter Monday at 7
a.m. and first of all that's that's a
pack right I mean I have to send it
because I told you not because you're
even going to read it right but if I
don't then I am you know $100 is going
to come into your account like maybe you
even already put it you know as like a
future thing which you can stop right so
there's a cost you put a cost to what
will happen if you don't do that
immediate
thing just goes to show I think
fundamentally that we're just driven by
incentives you know we think it's
something else but really at the very
fundamental level everything just seems
to be about incentives in business and
work relationships in life absolutely I
mean every decision every action
conscious or unconscious is very much
about incentives right the good and the
bad I think what's interesting to me is
that those incentives are quite variable
they can be money um they can be food
they can be like social interactions
variety they can be variety yeah so the
what the incentives are is very variable
what you know what the good that I'm
getting also the bad right what feels
bad a lot of different things can feel
bad so interesting so if you go if you
go down to like creatures low in The
evolutionary scale I think for them
things are more basic right for them
it's just like food temperature right
things like that that are really about
survival but as we go up and up and up
the ladder and we get to humans for us
there's a lot of different things that
can be incentivizing I was saying to one
of my colleagues the other day in a
business that I'm like a an investor in
he was telling me about one of his team
members who was like just a bit had lost
the love of the her work MH and he told
me the list of reasons she had said in
the like exit interview as to why she
wasn't enjoying her work and I looked at
the list of things and intuitively it
felt
like the person didn't actually know why
they weren't enjoying their work anymore
and so I had a conversation with this
person who was leaving this company and
um we got to the very bottom of it and
at the very heart of it was just a loss
of meaning in the job they were doing
they couldn't answer um why it mattered
anymore they thought the work they were
doing no longer mattered and when you'd
asked them they would have said a lot of
other things you know they would have
pointed small little things in this and
that and the office and whatever else
and the music that's playing and the but
at the very heart of it was actually
just an absence of meaning and people
aren't I don't think very good at
understanding that they've lost meaning
or that meaning is so important or that
what it is yeah and that goes back to
the survey that I mentioned um where
they found that the number one thing
that was important for people's
happiness was meaning and what does
meaning
mean me um I guess is that what you're
doing is
valuable right um yeah two so that's a
good question I think it's probably
Beyond yourself I don't know maybe it is
even something about
immortality right wanting to feel that
what I'm doing is going to change
something Beyond Myself um and it's it's
not necessarily about generosity
although you know generosity and could
be part of it but it's more about making
of a difference right Steve Job had had
this um saying that he he said something
like a dent in the universe right making
a dent in the universe I think a lot of
people want to do that and it you know
it don't have to invent the Mac to do
that it could also be how you affect
your family how you raise your children
right and that thing that those are the
kind of things that can continue to be
even when you're not there I've noticed
this
trend gen Z and the younger Millennials
are the change the world generation and
what I mean by that H out is that I have
so many young kids coming up to me
especially over the last what of 10
years generally that would say to me I
want to change the world and you'd ask
them like what do you mean they'd say
like I want to change the world um they
can't tell you necessarily what they
want to change about it but they want to
be the person that had that impact on
the world and I I think that sits in
contrast what my father would have said
as a 65y old man if you had asked him at
20 years old what do you want to do in
your job I don't think my dad would have
said change the world I think he would
have said I want to be a structural
engineer you know what I mean and I
think the going back to your point about
um habituation and people's desire to
like I don't know for immortality is it
plausible that because of social media
because we've seen a lot of world
changes we've adjusted our own I don't
know expectations of what are our own
contributions to now that this Young
Generation if they're not changing the
world or if they're not having such a
profound impact on things they don't
have the level of meaning has habituated
to now the base minimum of impact they
need to have is to change the world you
what I mean they can't just get a job
right and when I when I said about a
dent in the
world I did not mean as as I said before
I don't mean like inventing the Mac it
could just be making a nice meal that
people enjoy right or something it could
be it could be things that are quite
small and you know thinking about your
father he wants to be an engineer but he
wanted to be an engineer but why right
he said that's what he wanted to do but
why did he want that right so he
probably I don't know but maybe he
wanted to be that because that would
enable him to
create new things M right and so in just
creating new things you're changing the
world so I think I don't think he was
aiming at that though whereas the young
kids that come up to me they're like
aiming at that so they want to like they
want to change the world and they
haven't figured out how whereas my dad
wants to be like an engineer and the
consequences he ends up changing the
world yes but he probably wants to be an
engineer for some reason right I could
guess yes um and I think he doesn't you
know people don't think about it CH I
mean it's just we're using the same
words but I think these perhaps
different Generations have different
aspiration right um because changing the
world I when we say those when I say the
words I don't mean like changing the
world right I'm just saying saying doing
something that creates a change in your
world I mean maybe that's a better way
to do it better way to say it some kind
of change in your world not necessarily
I'm doing Global change like like Steve
Jobs but in some way this is a luxury
and that's true also even for your
father's generation and for this new
generation right wanting to have meaning
is a luxury that we have because we have
our basic needs right because we have
food and
shelter um and you know just like safety
the very very basic we can then start
think about meaning but on the other
hand you can say well just being able to
care for my family and keeping them safe
that also has meaning um risk in order
to to change our lives we have to sort
of lean into risk in key areas for those
people that are you know thinking about
changing their lives but they're looking
forward into uncertainty and they're
seeing risk and what advice would you
give them based on what you know about
habituation but more broadly from the
brain that's going to encourage them to
take that step into the unknown where
they believe risk lives yeah so we quote
the rock climber Alex hanold in in the
book and what he says is that that he
has a comfort zone which is kind of a
bubble around him and as he tries more
and more things that bubble just becomes
bigger and bigger and bigger he pushes
those boundaries and what happens is
that those things that seemed crazy to
him absolutely crazy then suddenly
become within the real of possibility
right I think the takeaway here is you
have to start you have to try and what
is helpful to know is that when even if
you try small so let's say there's you
their goal is quite up there it's like a
huge risk right yes but just try small
right and then suddenly The Next Step
wouldn't seem so crazy right and so on
and so forth we we see that you know
risk
habituates and it helps us explore
different things it helps us try new
things it can also go in a bad direction
right because of risk habituation what
is risk habituation risk habituation is
you do risky things when what we find is
that when people do risky things let's
say gamble we have a study where we let
people gamble um without letting them
know if they want or loss they just
gamble gamble gamble we tell them at the
end okay they gamble they start gambling
just a little bit and then they the next
they gamble more and more and more and
more right they feel more comfortable
with gambling less anxious right they
also feel less excited so they need to
gamble more and so risk really escalates
because our
emotions in response to risk habituate
so would risk escalate so that's
financial and I mean that could be a bad
thing right it's again it's like both
things are at the same time because you
might take huge risks because that that
you shouldn't really take we do this
with um virtual risk as well so uh we
want to put we we wanted to do is test
people's physical risk-taking but of
course we can't put them in danger so
what we did is we used virtual reality
and what we did is we used this game
where you put the headset on and then
you go up the elevator to a
skyscraper and you walk on a plank up up
up up in the air right it's all virtual
have you done this I have yes I did it
in New York City it was terrifying okay
yeah it's terf terrifying it's such a
puzz it's it's really interesting
experience because you know that you are
on the ground right I know that I'm in
my office I know that I'm safe but at
the same time my brain is completely
tricked yeah it's such you know it
really makes you feel quite humble and
how easy it is to trick your brain
you're feeling really scared and when we
let people do that they start off by
maybe taking one little step and two
little steps right and then the more
they do it they feel more comfortable
with it right they walk more and more
and more take more virtual risk until
you know 10 trials in they're jumping
right and we actually measure their
their anxiety we measure skin
conductance response and the more they
do it the less anxious they feel so they
take more risk and the less excited they
feel so they need more risk to take to
feel you know the same level of
excitement um yeah and I mean on one
hand they're exploring more in some
cases it could be dangerous for you and
you said in the book that people later
in their careers are more likely to have
accidents right um I think you said
athletes later in their career um have
accidents more and people on
construction sites um have more
accidents later on in the project than
at the start of the project because they
start to take more of those risks it
made me think about you know the the
study you talked about where you get
people to gamble but they can't see the
results yet of their Reckless Behavior
there's many areas of all of our lives
where we're gambling with something but
we can't yet see the results of that
behavior whether it's like with our
health or whether it's habits we have
like smoking I'm
smoking I'm uh eating this this junk
crap over here and because I haven't yet
had the results comeing the doctor
hasn't yet called me and told me there's
a problem I just keep going and my um
behavior Can escalate in those
departments until I get that phone call
which is like you've lost all your money
or you your health is you know you've
got something bad that's happened yeah
with long-term Investments right a lot
of the Investments fin Cal Investments
that we make are longterm right so we
may start small and then we grow grow
grow grow and we don't know the outcomes
until years later so something
collapses what you want people to to
come away from this conversation with
what is the uh the key
takeaway a lot of time people may not
feel so much joy in their life and then
they look around them and they conclude
that maybe I'm not feeling so much joy
because my relationship isn't that good
or you know my um job isn't that good
and you know maybe it is but maybe they
are good but they've just been the same
for a while so we have to be really
careful right and one way as you know we
mentioned what you could do is just like
spice it up a little bit shake it up a
little bit right and see what happens
and and vice versa a lot of times there
are things that are negatively affecting
your life and you don't know it because
they're always there social media is one
example that you might you might a lot
of people May suspect that social media
Instagram Twitter is causing them a
little bit of an anxiety a little bit of
of stress but they don't really know for
sure you can't measure it until you take
a break right it's a bit like the Acy
noise looming in the background you
don't notice it but when you stop when
you turn it off you're sing that's so
much better I didn't even realize that
this thing is causing me anxiety so I
think you know experiment I think you
know the last chapter in the book we We
call we call it experiments in living
experiment in living because it's really
hard to know what are the things that
are that are really good in your life
and what are the things that are not so
good in the life until you make some
changes take a break from social media
for a few weeks do something different
for you and then you will see you write
about people taking a break from social
media don't you yes there's a great um
experiment that was conducted by The
Economist hunt Alcott where he took
1,000 people he gave them $100 to get
off um off Facebook for a month and he
took another 1,000 individuals and they
gave them $100 to just continue what
they're doing at the end of the month he
came and he measured their well-being on
every single measure that he had those
people who quit for a month were happier
they were less anxious less depressed
less sad so in every measure they were
in the better state right and they were
surprised they had no idea that this was
going to have such a huge effect on them
but here's the even bigger surprise they
said that they were happier right they
fully admitted it but most of them
straight away at the end of the month
went back to Facebook
right um which is really interesting
because you acknowledge that this thing
is causing you you know a negative
effect on your health so when do you go
back I think there's two reasons one is
you gain information and knowledge that
knowledge may you know it may not make
you feel good but we value knowledge and
information and that's perhaps one
reason why the people went back um it
could also be something like addiction I
mean a lot of things um in life that
you're addicted to you kind of know
they're not good for you you know
they're not causing you have but there's
need right there's something pushing you
there was this crazy stat I read in your
book about the impact that leaving
social media had had on people equated
to getting a $30,000 pay rise at work
something like that so that that yeah it
was a study that was conducted by um an
Italian uh
scientist and what he he did he noticed
that when Facebook first started in 2004
it just started at harv right and then a
while later they went on to you know a
lot of ivy league universities one by
one very slowly and then 2008 they
opened up to the world and what he found
is that in every University that it
Facebook was introduced mental health
went down what was the reason he could
do the study is that the university had
measures of people's well-being they you
know because they actually measure it
quite often and he can see in every
University mental health went down every
University and then in the population
um Facebook was introduced in 2008 in
the next 10 years the EP depression
episodes were increased by 80% now you
don't know quation none of this tells
you quation it is only correlational
right interesting but you know he so
he's claiming that using statistical
methods he estimates that potentially a
quarter of this decline in mental health
can be due to uh social media again you
can't really it's not a and this is why
the other experiment is a little bit
better because it's he the other
experiment hunt alcot manipulated
whether people were online or not so he
could actually do a control experiment
and measure it right um so he could show
cation this other study that suggests
25% of mental health um decline was
caused um due to social media that's a
correlational um result but you know
there could be some truth in it we have
a closing tradition on this podcast
where the last guest leaves a question
for the next guest not knowing who
they're leaving it for and the question
left for you is what is one thing that
people who are listening could do that
you
know about that would improve their
lives how about something
simple how about people just now email
call turn to someone and tell them they
love
them it would not you know doesn't
doesn't completely change your life but
it will change your feelings at that
very
moment Ty thank you really enjoyed the
conversation and I'm uh so fascinated by
your work and it's a real service to
humanity what you do so thank you so
much it's been a pleasure thank
you a quick word on hu as you know
they're a sponsor of this podcast and
I'm an investor in the company after
years and years and years and years of
work and literally I remember being in
the boardroom about 2 to three years ago
at hu when they were working on this
product finally hu have nailed the
Complete Nutrition bar honestly it's
been one of the most popular
conversations at hu for the last three
years how do we make a bar that is
nutritionally complete that has 27
minerals and vitamins and that is low in
sugar taste good I would have more of
them to show you had I not eaten them
all I mean they arrived at the office
yesterday and my team just scoffed them
all down and the last one you can see
it's actually ripped here because as one
of our team members went to eat it
someone shouted no we need that tomorrow
for the hu ad check it out I know people
are loving hu greens at the moment
because you guys have just plasted my
DMs asking for hu Greens in the UK but
in the meantime before hu Daily Greens
comes to the UK you've got to check out
the bars they've just dropped because
they are
delicious do you need a podcast to
listen to next we've discovered that
people who liked this episode also tend
to absolutely love another recent
episode we've done so I've linked that
episode in the description below I know
you'll enjoy
[Music]
it